delegates from more than 190 countries
and bodies gathered in Peru amid rising
demands for a lasting deal and rising
global temperature the movie pledges and
there will be engagements not only from
the rich countries but also from the
developing countries and that's good the
? will be and I don't have the answer
will it be enough to reach our target of
not more than two degrees warming up
leading the campaign for europe emmy
peas and climate action and energy
commissioner miguel arias kenyatta in
october the EU agreed to forty percent
cuts in co2 emissions by 2030 shortly
after the US and China signaled a joint
and from any unexpected agreement to cut
levels by up to twenty eight percent in
the next ten years fueling hope in Lima
there is a well for one on this but it
will take courage and it will mean all
countries moving to the edge of their
comfort zones many are calling for the
wall between poor and rich countries to
be dismantled but how if the poor blame
the rich for global warming saying they
must pay and the rich say the burden now
needs to be shared and what about
long-term strategies stop the causes
through mitigation or help people
affected adapt to change or a mix we
should all strive for an agreement that
as mitigation a detection and climate
finance s essential parts and that is in
line with a lot of science and the new
findings in agreement where commitments
can be regularly review it and which
remain feet for puspos long after 2020
this conference was about preparing for
the UN climate summit in Paris this time
next year plenty of time you might think
to iron out differences not so you do
feel that everyone is much more serious
about reaching a deal than for example
five years ago in Copenhagen but in the
end the real issues on financing
mitigation level who's going to do what
how are we going to control that how are
we going to evaluate that not did not
really resolve so a lot of difficult
issues up with spawns till next year in
Paris unfortunately a thought shared by
some Peruvians like this fish seller
who's seen stocks diminish over the
years right all these meetings and the
next
one that will be in France maybe this
will bring us together and make us more
thoughtful despite the compromises
delegates noted one other advance the
shrinking space for climate change
deniers in the face of evidence of
rising sea levels and melting ice
together threatening the lives of
millions of people